[Music]
happy birthday thank you i'm feeling
really good this is technically your
first interview yes have you been
waiting
to talk i'm definitely excited now that
i can
everybody's 18. that also means
something important for you yes i am
free free
there's no more custody court right
we're done it's old today it's over i
call today emancipation day no offense
honey i love you it is just a big relief
being 18 also means that you now get all
that money that you earned as a kid on
tv i do i mean i don't know how much it
is but i've always said like when i do
get the money that i'm gonna use it to
pay for my college okay let's just sing
happy birthday and you also got a
message from your mom today i did she
just you know wished me happy birthday
you know told me she loved me it was
great how is your relationship today
with your mom my relationship with my
mom is pretty
stable like we text each other and call
each other
on like
an average basis on a day like today do
you miss your siblings oh 100 i miss my
siblings
since 2016 hannah has lived with john
brother colin joined later the rest of
the sextuplets alexis aiden joel and
leah live with kate why did you choose
to live with your father i've always
been closer to my dad i just feel like
there was
unfair treatment in my mom's house and
when you say unfair do you mean unfair
towards your brother colin yeah my
brother colin did kind of take
you know the front of it sometimes john
was awarded full custody of colin in
2018 after he spent two years in a
treatment center for what kate called
special needs john says that isn't true
i mean i didn't see colin for like five
six years i had to learn a lot about his
difficulties from living with kate and
being away communication with my
children that live with kate is very
difficult because i have been alienated
from those children i think it was a
poor parenting decision will you try to
reach out to them now i've already
texted them but i've never got a
response
so this is
one of the most famous houses in tv
history oh yeah this used to be all fans
and the paparazzi used to line up on the
other side of the white fence there and
the gate the girls will tell you that
mommy you're boring daddy's fun the
groundbreaking reality series first
premiered in 2007 and became one of
tlc's highest rated programs ever with
kate's hair becoming halloween's go-to
costume the lady that did my hair makeup
was awesome she became one of the most
recognizable people in this country she
also became one of the most hated she's
the karen
can you stop breathing so loud honey
he's like
she's the karen meme she is
like hello you need to stop playing toys
and come help do you ever wish these two
could have gotten the law
always yeah it would be nice to know
stand in a room with them and not
think
that they hate each other but
they still
both love me so it's fine things are
clearly still very contentious between
john and kate in the nearly 13 years
since their 2009 split kate and i have
decided to separate i'm not very fond of
the idea personally
10.6 million viewers tuned in to watch
their televised separation announcement
john now claims the network covered up
the real reason their 10-year marriage
ended why did the divorce happen yeah
because a certain person left me
for a certain somebody john alleges that
certain somebody worked closely with his
family on the series there was this
relationship that was going on in front
of you yep what did you say when you
found out
oh i knew i was like end it kate has
always denied having an affair everybody
loves reunions
do you think there'll be a time where
all eight of you will get back together
again yeah i mean there's always a
possibility we still talk about it and i
wanted this like to do a reunion kind of
thing
but um i got shot down amongst kate and
a couple other uh siblings so if you
could say something decay today what
would you say tell the truth
what are you hiding from
[Music]